did I notice a little like sparkly new
and mysteries all that - yeah between
you when we go back in to give the
verdict see if you can get some like try
to wink at her I can't I am physically
incapable of Lincoln try winking like I
said I could shut them both in the open
one a clear bond really makes getting
high look like science I mean did you
see how mad the daughter was the mother
for going out and hanging out down low
yeah payday loan should just be for like
a ransom situation that's the only time
you should ever go to a payday loan
place what did you write down in there
what do you notes
this says Costco and I just underlined
it a couple times because I like Costco
and I you know I feel solution to their
problem is just the old driver to Costco
B I could take mystery takasho
occasionally cuz I'm chalk elites of the
world jug of salted caramel this is I
I'm a citron Acacio maybe like in the
moment you can wink are you thinking a
tour when we get in there you think you
just cuz I want to see you double boy
Connor the winter wonk when when you
pass times like it well what words never
a word wonk wonk is never lets wait
because of when would you ever tell a
story where you winked in the past let
me tell you a story where someone winked
at me yeah okay I was at the Oscars
hanging around outside the Oscars after
was over yeah yeah
burt lancaster winks at me Burt
Lancaster
straight up winked at me really yeah you
went like this yeah
just like haha it's a school haha it was
the best way kind of a god if Burt
Lancaster has ever told this story
[Music]